Sébastien Véronique et leur fils de 4
ans vivent au motel depuis un mois parce
qu'ils ont été évincés de leur maison
louée qui grugeaient 90% de leur revenu
d'aide sociale quand on a eu la lettre
des déductions
je voyais pas de solutions
qui quand même des terrains de chasse ou
ce que j'aurais pu aller planter notre
temps puis dormez là la pénurie de
logements surtout abordable fera
possible les petites villes pour les
municipalités de 10 à 50 000 habitants
le tour d'inoccupation moyen était de
2,2% en octobre 2022 mais malgré cette
crise les projets de logements
abordables prennent beaucoup de temps
sur ce terrain donné par Mont-Laurier un
projet de 30 logements abordables
patauge depuis 10 ans que ça demeure un
terrain vague après 10 ans normal
absolument pas normal absolument pas
comme bien d'autres maires il est
exaspéré par la lenteur des programmes
de subventions en logements abordable
tout le monde reconnaît que la lourdeur
administrative fait que les projets
n'avancent pas les organismes
communautaires qui élaborent ces projets
sont du même avis est-ce que c'est
compliqué oui il y a trop d'acteurs
souvent différents paniers qui sont
décisionnels qu'on attend toujours après
une décision après quelqu'un d'autre
mais on peut aller plus rapidement ici
la maison lise Beauchamp un organisme
sans but lucratif termine 16 logements
sociaux et ce seulement deux ans après
le début du projet un projet issu de
l'Initiative pour la création rapide de
logements lancés par Ottawa en 2020
l'objectif était d'accélérer la
construction en simplifiant les choses
ce qui est plus simple c'est qu'on peut
choisir notre contracteur n'est pas
obligé d'aller en soumission publique ce
qui est plus simple je peux choisir mon
mon
architecte je peux choisir mon ingénieur
je peux choisir mon électricien si je
veux depuis 2020 ce programme a permis
de construire
3158 logements au Québec plus de 10000
pour l'ensemble du Canada Michel Bolduc
est formel l'issrl permet d'aller
beaucoup plus vite que les programmes
actuels de Québec moi je dirais ça a été
ces trois fois plus rapide
au moins
2 juillet les locataires vont
s'installer dans les 16 nouveaux
logements sociaux dont Sébastien et sa
famille
d'ici là Sébastien travaille à fabriquer
les armoires de son propre appartement
grâce à un programme de réinsertion de
la maison lise Beauchamp qui mène aussi
la construction des 16 logements sociaux
c'est avec fierté que Sébastien amène sa
famille dans son futur domicile
un appartement tout neuf enfin un
domicile salubre
de mauvais proprio
et la famille ne consacrera que 30% de
ses revenus à payer le loyer je tape pas
capable de fournir toi ma famille le
score vraiment peine de la bâtir
valorisant puis en même temps mais ça
rend ma femme heureuse ça rend mon petit
garçon heureux un appartement qui est
aussi beaucoup sur ce de dignité
peut-être un nouveau départ pour toute
la famille
ici David gentil les réseaux Canada Mont
Laurier grand